so the question is can president trump  pardon all of the people who  participated in the capital rights and  laid  siege to the capitol well unfortunately  the answer to that is almost certainly  yes  if president trump remains the president  this is probably one of the primary  reasons why it would be a good idea to  impeach and remove him  before he finishes out his term to  prevent this and other all sorts of  really terrible pardons while the  constitution does say the president  can't pardon people in terms of  impeachment this probably is not what  that clause of the constitution means so  yeah there's probably nothing that would  prevent a sitting president trump from  pardoning all the rioters  now of course that's for federal crimes  but unfortunately the president's pardon  power does extend to district of  columbia crimes  as well so stay tuned for more legal  election coverage and as always  i'll see you in court